we've had um several people who are
running for office on the show and we've
tried to get
several people who are currently in
office i think i could be wrong but i
think you're the first person who's
actually currently sitting in political
office who's come on the show and uh you
know just the way we were talking
earlier uh before the show started it
just and we'll have that up as a special
episode on the websites the green room
we show the whole behind the scenes you
you seem like a regular person
and so uh with that
tell us about what your experience has
been like entering congress
because um i gotta say a lot of people
probably have this this vision where
like you go in you know it's your first
term and you create a bill and then
everyone stamps it
yeah yeah you were telling us about how
they just like do voice votes yes oh my
gosh i want everyone to know this and if
you hate me you still need to know this
okay so when i got kicked off committees
i was like all right i'm brand new here
i want to learn how this place works um
and and here's what else you need to
understand if you're the minority party
nobody has no one in the minority party
has control on committees the majority
party has control on committees so if
democrats are in control they're
controlling the committees and they
control what bills are actually voted on
republicans have no choice we can't put
a bill to the floor unless we have 218
signatures to pull it out and we don't
have 218. so being in the minority
committees are pointless for us so i got
kicked off committees and i was like
okay big deal so i go sit on the house
floor just sitting there watching what's
happening because again i've never been
elected i've never held office i didn't
even go to the local gop meetings
because i thought they were silly and
stupid until now until now yeah and then
i go but here's here's what happens so
they were debating a bill back and forth
and they're debating it back and forth
and there was someone sitting in nancy
pelosi's seat the speaker's chair was
not nancy pelosi i don't know who it was
because they had a mask on and everybody
wears mask and i was like okay i don't
know who that is it was actually a man
so they're debating back and forth and
then the guy up there holding the gavel
in the speaker's chair
calls for
the vote by voice
so the democrats there was about five of
them on their side we there was about
five republicans on our side the
democrats it's their bill so they're
like yay and they're saying
yay they want to vote for it the
republicans on our side they're used to
getting defeated at this point because
we're into february and they're saying
they go nay without enthusiasm and then
all of a sudden the guy up there speaker
mask face he gavels it in
the bill has passed and i was like
i'm sitting here holding my voting card
in my hand and i'm like i didn't vote
and i was so confused so i called one of
the republican floor staffers and i'm
like what just happened and he goes
ma'am
that's that's how we pass bills the bill
just passed and i was like i said what
are you talking about there's 435
members of congress there's like 10
people that said yay and nay i didn't
even vote i didn't say anything there's
a machine so here's what we have
on every other row there's a little
machine it looks like a credit card
machine and i have an id card it looks
like a driver's license as a member of
congress you put it in there and there's
three buttons you can push you can push
green for yes red for no and then
there's a yellow one that's for present
i don't know why you need present but
whatever
so i didn't get to vote no one else
voted it was not recorded so here's what
i found out
most of the bills in congress are passed
with a voice vote meaning millions and
millions and billions of american
taxpayer dollars
are passed that way remember when they
they had like that little ra the wagon
they carried the 5 000 pages in on do
you remember that what was that what was
that
yeah that should be
i mean what come on
we elect someone to read the bills and
to decide if they're good or not that's
their job oh my goodness you i i agree
with you we should read the bills
because i can tell you there's horrible
things in them isn't it crazy that
you're saying 25 million for butterflies
i love butterflies but do i want to
spend what about 25 million dollars for
desert fish well what about desert fish
10 million dollars for pakistani gender
studies programs oh so important
pakistanis don't know what gender they
are how many genders do pakistanis have
why are american taxes
and speed boats for sri lanka i remember
that one too off the top of my head but
i don't i don't believe i don't believe
in many laws but i definitely uh believe
in the law that congressmen and women
should read the bill before they vote on
it i also believe in term limits and on
mandatory drug testing of members of
congress where do you stand on those all
those three issues okay wait i gotta
tell you one more thing hold on hold on
libertarian luke
as long as the government creates laws
to govern itself fine otherwise stay out
of my business i think people should be
allowed to do psychedelics yeah drugs
yeah yeah but but a lot of the you know
the the i get your representatives are
not at work though because then believe
me they're not reading the bills
trust me if you would find out what the
politicians are really up to especially
when they're flying on those airplanes
and hanging on those islands and hanging
out with mr epstein you would want to
know exactly what they're doing and i
wouldn't want mandatory drug testing for
all of them because
there's some funny business to say the
least that is you don't want somebody on
drugs making a chili cheese dog
whatever i don't care about that let
them let them have more drugs if they're
making my chili cheese like i don't
they're
that is a good point though if the
government law is on the government
actors themselves they have to be
they have to be enforced by themselves
too so if there's regulations and
restrictions on small business they have
to abide by those same laws in their
private lives so i think that would be
absolutely fair and would lead to people
of course not passing more more bull
crap so so three issues mandatory drug
testing term limits and making sure that
people read every uh word of the bill
that they pass where do you think about
those three really quickly all right i
definitely don't think anyone should be
on drugs or drinking when they're at
work i just i'm i as an employer i would
be very upset if my employees were
drinking or on drugs it's dangerous but
just government employees well of course
guys so i'm employed by my district and
so i my goodness
what a horrible person i would be if i
was at work on drugs or drinking
they would fire me they should fire me
that's what i that's how i view that um
what was your other one mandatory term
limits okay so you know who the problem
is who
the staff
the staff never leaves guess what
so i'm gonna go into this a little bit
when i became a member of congress i was
given so here's how it works you guys
every member of congress is allotted a
certain amount of money per year
so for my district my allotment is 1.4
million dollars with 1.4 million dollars
i have to hire my staff i have to pay
for district offices it's like a mini
business each member of congress is like
a mini business and you have to stay
within those bounds if i spend more than
that guess what i have to pay for it out
of my campaign funds so that's a big
no-no right so 1.4 million dollars but
here's the deal so when i went to
washington and i had to hire staff i'm
like who do i hire well guess what
there's a whole bunch of people that
there was the president trump just left
office there's a bunch of people looking
for jobs the staff in washington never
leaves that's the deep state i would
hire the homeless people in washington
dc if i was a congress maybe like come
off the streets don't even take a shower
just come on in personally myself
there's a guy named perspective brick
for dictator he rides around and and
yeah but anyways vermin supreme yes
he would be my chief of staff
so he's uh he's a satirical candidate
who has a boot on his head oh i haven't
seen him i went i went to a crazy
festival with him one year he's wild but
really interesting and a great guy so we
talk about the administrative state
being like the head of the fbi j edgar
hoover 40 years at the head of the fbi
administrative state all the way deep
state whatever and so you're saying that
the actual staff congressional staff is
also part of that administrative state
like they're just oh my gosh yeah and
they'll go from working in a democrat
office to work in a republican office
it's a job so let me let me clarify it's
a job turn limits for everyone
including the bureaucracy well so here's
some other things so let's say every
um i think the term i signed the term
limits pledge by the way
but i don't want to term limit myself
unless everyone else is term limited
because guess what that is oh yeah that
would be like leaving and then leaving
all the bad people in there so that
doesn't make sense um but if you
so here's something ten thousand hour
rule has any has anyone ever heard of
that ten thousand hours
oh my gosh you're an expert um so if i
played that guitar behind you for 10 000
hours i'm should be pretty good
yeah i would hope so um but anyways so
if you
if you're there for only six years or
for i think senators 12 years
you by the time you become an expert you
leave
and so i don't really know that all the
problems can be solved i know this i
want the good people to stay in and
fight and fix the problems so the term
limit the term limit issue is really
interesting if you only term limit the
members and of congress and the senators
but you never term limit the staff
and the changes there then essentially
you're not solving any problems yeah
that's why i say term limit uh all of
them i think it's rotten to the core and
i think the more we have new people in
there the less government does and that
to me
any kind of expert in government i don't
like because they're doing more
government stuff but that's my own
personal opinion and we could agree to
disagree with that
regime change yeah and neocon wars that
of course don't produce anything and
destroy american uh soldiers lives
destroy our economy and absolutely just
fill the bank roles for multinational
corporations like halliburton that are
able to make too much money lockheed
martin all of them are just absolutely
controlling a lot of our policy that
also just quite benefits them at the
same time it's crazy what's happening in
washington dc i say fire all of them
myself but that's just my personal
perspective and opinion
i'm i'm telling people uh vote in the
primaries oh primaries are where it's at
get rid of all the neocons the
establishments not the general it i mean
generals are important the primaries are
it the primary is the place where um if
it's a republican district they really
can pick a conservative versus a
moderate there's that opportunity in the
primary if it's a democrat district they
can pick a progressive versus a more
moderate democrat primaries are the most
important place to vote then you got to
get them across the line in the general
primaries are everything um but i want
to talk about uh roll calling votes so
back to that story you guys
when i found out that they could pass
bills by voice i also learned floor
procedure so it's like it's like games
right there's rules on each of us what
we can do so the next time the bill came
up and they were debating the bill back
and forth and i was really paying
attention this time and i had my lovely
little book in my lap that i had the
rules
they the speaker up there speaker mask
face is what i call them because i
didn't know who it was
he he asked for the vote the voice vote
and this time so the democrats are like
yay and the republicans over here nay
because they're used to losing
and right as
speaker mask face is about to say to
gavel it in announce the bill has passed
the rule is as a member of congress and
any of us can do it you have to get to
the microphone right then and you have
to say
madame speaker i asked for the recorded
vote and i did call him madam speaker
because gender doesn't count according
to our rules sorry anyone
but i did say that i said madam speaker
i asked for the recorded vote so here's
what happened
it was like uh
just a complete change
when i asked for that that means at that
moment they have to call all 435 members
of congress no matter where they are
to come down and vote on that bill and
everyone is on record that means you can
look up how your member your
representative voted you can look up
your member your representative you can
look up your member people can look me
up and go did she vote for that or did
she vote no for that what did what did
they do what did what did aoc vote what
did uh dan crenshaw vote what did
eric swalwell what did fang fang tell
eric swalwell to vote you know they can
do all this stuff so here's the here's
the deal recorded votes are so important
so i committed myself to that and i kept
on asking for recorded votes and i kept
on asking for recorded votes and i
pissed everybody off i'm talking about
royally good here's what happened so
every time they got called they got
called out of their uh
committee meeting they got called out of
their lunch with lobbyists they got
called out of their fundraising calls
that they were sitting there begging for
money
they had to wake jerry nadler up from
his nap i mean it was unbelievable
everybody had to come in and vote what
else did it do
it messed up the schedule nancy was very
upset because they had a whole schedule
they were bills were flying through and
all of a sudden they weren't flying
through anymore
cory bush's bill i defeated her bill it
was really important her bill actually
passed by voice until i asked for the
reported votes which bill which bill was
it it would have allowed
felons in prison to vote oh wow that's
what her bill did
so it won by the voice but then when you
double checked it they're like oh we
made a mistake
when i asked for the recorded votes even
democrats voted against her wow we had
318 i believe it was 318 no votes on
cory bush's bill to allow felons in
prison to vote so when people say
marjorie taylor green has not been
effective in congress i'm going to tell
you something right now i've got stories
for days i will argue i've been one of
the most effective members of congress
because i have put and led the effort to
put the entire united states congress on
record so that democrats can look up
their representative and say how did my
democrat that i voted for vote
republicans how did my republican
representative vote i think this is
extremely important for everyone across
the country to know the job performance
of their representative the
establishment can't be happy with you oh
no i got in trouble with republicans too
as a matter of fact i got chewed
out
i mean chewed out you want to know why
marjorie
people don't want to be on record no no
meaning they don't want their
constituents to know how they voted
i want that person on record saying that
yeah that's dirty can you say who it was
i'm not forcing you to but virginia fox
dangerous that that's those things
all that should be on record i mean i
i've gotten to the point where i tell it
all you want to know why because i think
it's important because the way they have
treated me no one defended me
no one defending me this is i you saw me
get kicked off committees
then there were 11 republicans that
voted with democrats kicked me off
committees because of things they didn't
like that i said on facebook years
before i ever ran for congress or became
a member of congress it didn't matter
what i was when i walked in and swore in
or who i was didn't matter my great life
record my career the fact that i've
never been arrested i've never done
drugs that i've raised three amazing
children none of that mattered to them
it was we don't like a few things on
facebook what maybe she liked or this
she possibly said or or anything
they kicked me off for that and then no
one defended me yep no one defended me
and no one helped me that really really
pissed me off because ilhan omar of
course you know has said things that
have been condemned across the board and
they defend her
when when i refer to what she says as
crop dusting anti-semitism meaning like
the plane gets real close to the ground
she wasn't overtly saying it but
sometimes it does she kept saying things
that we're getting a lot of people to
say like hey like when you say it one
time we're kind of like maybe there's a
mistake maybe you don't understand but
when you do it over and over again
now regardless of whether anyone's
really offended what bothers me is the
democrats would condemn you but defend
her there's no principle it's just it's
just political it's it's political war
yeah it's political whatever they can do
to hurt you and defend their side when
you were saying that the majority uh
gets the the committees basically is
that like because if there's a majority
of democrats minority republicans they
go to every committee and put that ratio
on every committee so there are ratios
and that's a great question so it's a
majority controlled body that's what how
congress works and so whoever the
majority party is and right now it's the
democrats they get to control each
committee meaning that the democrat
chairman the chairman of each committee
will be a democrat and that chairman of
each committee say chairman of judiciary
which is jerry nadler he will control
which
investigations they do he gets to
control which bills judiciary committee
which bills come out of judiciary and
which bills go to the floor that we all
vote on and so a majority controlled
congress means that the democrats or
republicans whoever's the majority
controls from all the committees it's
kind of like a party yeah like a like
like they just say well this we have it
now this is our uniparty but like maybe
if it was 60 40 and like the republicans
chaired 40 of the committees and the
democrats chaired the other 60 that
might not work no and they've tried that
before
how it works is no whoever is the
majority controlling party they control
all the committees thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time
you